[Music]
yeah like you just pop back in my life
whenever you want to after what you did
to me I don't think so yeah that is
unacceptable ah it is 11:45 the nerve
who said you could text me in the
morning ya know he is obnoxious it's
disrespectful I am working he what her
you should be oh my god you know what he
probably saw me on Instagram so I got my
hair braided so I hadn't a new little
jumpsuit posted a picture the other day
it was fire yeah
probably was like let me get in here
mess data say something to her ruin her
day yeah I bet most likely that was
exactly what are you saying just that
mother didn't knew I won some lunch with
Sam really the other day and I posted a
picture of it it was real cute we look
like a beautiful black couple in love he
probably got mad and was like let me go
in there and mess things up mess that
relationship up make them argue make
things fall apart gonna get into a fight
with Samuel over this no Kate I'm just
saying that's probably what he wanted
sure Samuel now hey baby you left it on
the stove Samuel not me
you left it on the stove Samuel no it
was you I am at work
don't call me while I'm at work and say
these things we will discuss it when I
get home
well maybe just texting back buddy Kate
and give me the satisfaction of hearing
from me are you come on use your brain
for like a millisecond okay you know I'm
new to all this ex stuff so damn I know
what I'm gonna do no Texas aspect hold
up yeah Quinta that'll show up I know
right okay I need to say something
that's like I'm that [ __ ] but you
better not call me a [ __ ] oh well so
I'm gonna slide you like you a [ __ ]
maybe just like hi
smart okay hi that'll show ya look at
impressed text that already
don't you have some work to do
yeah I feel like you have something do
are you her manager how's your first day
god it's it's unbearable
oh the summer's over what I don't know
I'm gonna get some more coffee from the
kitchen do you want anything no I'm good
okay hey babe yeah now I don't want to
tell you how to live your life
nope if I want to watch a seven hour
marathon I'm naked and afraid' that's
what I'm gonna do and you need to
support me because you're my man no but
don't you think you should be getting
like some water instead of coffee hmm
you don't drink enough water I never see
you drink it
[Music]
clean the memory because I can't reach
[Music]
really I'd rather just not clean it
there's so much beginning there see
perhaps in my water hmm that's okay
quick I think I might have some Hennessy
keep something back for
[Music]
look I get enough water okay there's
water and everything fruits veggies
Milky Way bars not enough oh gosh the
less water I have the more there is for
people in need nope you hater dog
don't call me dog I don't drink
bitch-ass water every day and I'm fine I
begged you didn't I just drink it what's
the problem it has no taste all right
it's flavorless juice it mocks me with
its clearness I don't like it it's
annoying Quinta here drink the water I'm
doing this for you
it's good for you I can't believe I have
to say this to its 27 year old woman
fine give me the water I'll drink it
okay
drink it it doesn't burn I did I'm so
proud of you I'm gonna get you another
one hold up
take it easy baby steps but if you could
give me one glass of Hennessy and some
coffee that'd be great
maybe some melted butter too what are
you so encouraging huh thank you baby I
know what I do it out you
[Music]
so it's like you're not a bill collector
student debt collector I know you know
yeah I don't really have any power and I
told them then I'm fine
oh it's buckets yeah whatever
so anyway I said you'll see your money
when I see my degree nice
good bird mm-hmm remember where do you
build that shut up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me first
I didn't mean to trip you I didn't want
to do that
my want is simple my want is to exist
I'm sorry
you remember tripping me and you talk of
course I have nothing to think about all
day besides the things that I see or the
people I've tripped you were one of
three today and I remember your shoes
okay well yes you tripped me and I
remember that too
and since you could talk I'd like an
apology
I guess Quinta how do you know my name
it says it on your underwear Quinta if
you'd like an apology from me occur I'll
give you one but consider this perhaps
what you're most upset about is that
I've reminded you of your own mortality
reminded you that even on your best days
something can go wrong and that your
limbs you are precious limbs and the
skills that you've had walking since two
years old can betray you what I think I
remind you of most of all is that you
are imperfect head-up sweet human this
shouldn't make you sad I am perfect okay
but I cannot move I cannot feel I cannot
you're stuck
so I guess what you're saying is that I
should accept my imperfections that they
make me human still alive precisely
that's some good advice curve you have
any more wise words you know since we're
here talking yes stop falling asleep
with Netflix on your dreams become very
odd
[Music]
[Music]